Lindsay Lohan's close friend hope it
Galan is speaking out about the drama
surrounding the actresses personal life
the TV host opened up to ETS Jennifer
perros on Wednesday calling all the
rumors pure speculation and clarified
quote she's not been speaking to anyone
including her family she's been on a
total time out any interviews given
about her are completely not true hope
it shared this sweet selfie to Instagram
Monday puckering up to Lindsey who she's
on vacation with in corsica France she
explained quote Lindsey hasn't even had
her phone with her she's enjoying a
lovely holiday and some downtime now in
Europe with her girlfriends she's
working her matter out privately as she
stated sometimes the best therapy is a
pause that matter is seemingly in
reference to the series of social media
posts Lindsey shared over the weekend
including this shot where she called out
her fiance for quote not coming home but
on Tuesday the 30 year old actress
assured her fans she's doing well and
apologized for publicly exposing her
personal life